this ancient message took centuries to
crack we could always read this message
we still have no clue how to read this
message why
what if history were hiding something
from you
would you want to know about it well if
you stick with me a few minutes we'll
start getting you to think like a
decipher then you can join the club and
hold a flickering lamp up to an old wall
and with you're perceptive gaze not
slowly an enlightened appreciation of
the symbols I'll bring the symbols and
techniques you're buying the Hat in the
lamp though if you stay for this series
we'll tell tales of decipherment that
take us from the sands of Egypt through
the Central American jungle to the
middle of the Pacific you'll work
alongside history's great decoders and
some crackpots in their relentless
attempts to recover voices long vanished
we already saw what decipherment is not
like cryptography or crypt analysis but
what is it yes like decipherment is
something we do with the message we
can't read that was a bit vague let's go
again decipherment is an operation
performed on an unknown message and it
requires two components first a script a
writing system these visual itched inked
carved whatever its symbols that were
eager to read mocking us silently across
the ages are called glyphs to the
meaningful units we're trying to
identify among these glyphs are called
graphemes the other thing we need is a
language if there's no language
underlying the symbols at all there's no
linguistic message to decipher some
claim this is true of the Indus scripts
or the tart Aria tablets before this
video you talked about decipherment the
way people normally do deciphering
symbols to dig up the hidden ancient
message inside of them we built on that
by admitting that we have to identify
the messages writing system and its
language to unearth its meaning that's
our first understanding of decipherment
let's call it model one but if you're
joining our secret Club you have to
change the way you look at decipherment
decipherment binds certain language bits
to certain writing bits and sees if they
chord
made if the message reads naturally with
that writing system and that language
model number one I really don't like
these names let's see this one has
layers or kind of hidden guts and this
one is matching pieces hidden guts is
more romantic more ocular but what
happens when some hack Decipherer comes
along and challenges your reading hidden
guts tells you to peer through the
greffi McKay's like a kind of seer sage
matching pieces invites you to compare
texts and find a best fit it even
invites predictions when we find texts
and more texts in the language it's a
fresh starting point for thinking about
how to decipher but what can you
decipher what can't you decipher that's
actually a great question for next time